Good evening, America.
There are decisions that we are
asked to make in our lifetimes
that are truly humbling.
Inside that building right now.
The powers that be are
negotiating your future.
Burdick:
Decisions that in previous times
would have been
left to the gods.
Hologram:
But you can’t negotiate
with a fire,
or a flood,
or a famine.
We must save ourselves.
Extrapolations has sort
of an interesting
origin story.
After I was involved in the
making of An Inconvenient Truth,
one of the questions
that I asked myself was,
as a storyteller, how do
we take the science
and move it into more
conventional, scripted
storytelling?
In episode one, we
really established
the chaos of the world.
Sienna Miller:
There's famine, there are fires.
The world is a pretty
unsafe place to live in.
Scott Burns: Anytime you’re
looking into the future,
you're asked to make
some speculations.
How's the world gonna look?
What's gonna change?
It’s an enormous theme
played on an
enormous stage
with very personal,
small stories,
which is why I think
it's so relatable.
The shows that pretend that the
climate is going to be the same
in ten or fifteen years,
those are the science
fiction shows because
the climate is changing.
The nature of the show
lends itself to
really not being able to know
what you're gonna get.
The cliffhangers aren't for
the immediate moment after
it's for what's gonna
happen in five years.
My family's never
leaving, you know.
We would come and hear you speak
even if we had to tread
water the entire time.
That's a comforting
thought.
It's very vivid.
One of the great things
about the stories in here
is that it manages to
shrink them down
to small personal moments.
Scott Burns:
The cast is huge.
The first person I
spoke to was Meryl.
She read the script
and said, "okay, when
are we doing this?"
Sienna Miller
was so excited to play
Meryl Streep’s daughter.
You want me to read
for a while, mom?
No, no, no. I'm-
You're going to be here.
I'm not.
Scott Burns:
Yara Shahidi is very powerful.
Hari Neff is spectacular.
Edward Norton
is about as passionate
and as eloquent
a person as I've ever met.
Gemma Chan,
Tahar Rahim,
Diane Lane,
Tobey Maguire,
Eiza Gonzales,
Forest Whitaker,
Marion Cotillard,
and Kit.
Kit Harington is sort of
the connective tissue
in this entire series.
Good evening, everyone.
I hope
people can find every
emotion in it,
including hope.
I think the way that
you find comfort
is imagining yourself
in the positions that
our characters are in.
We’re not gods.
We're just parents and children,
please come home, pal.
Daveed Diggs:
I hope people are entertained,
I certainly am.
The scripts are
beautifully shot.
There's jokes like, it's funny.
Dorothy Fortenberry:
The show, ultimately,
every episode is about
people finding each other,
people finding ways to team up.
New friends, fellow citizens,
and they can find a
way to work together.